U.S. OPEN.
WILL THIS BE HER FINAL RUN AT A
MAJOR?
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE WATCHING AT
THIS HOUR.
I'M ERICA HILL, IN FOR KATE
BALDWIN.
WE BEGIN WITH A DIRE SITUATION
IN MISSISSIPPI.
THE STATE'S CAPITAL, JACKSON,
WITHOUT RELIABLE DRINKING WATER
AFTER THE PUMP AT THE TREATMENT
FACILITY FAILED.
SOME RESIDENTS HAVE LITTLE OR NO
WATER IN THEIR HOMES.
MISSISSIPPI'S GOVERNOR DECLARING
A WATER EMERGENCY.
>> UNTIL IT IS FIXED, IT MEANS
WE DO NOT HAVE RELIABLE RUNNING
WATER AT SCALE.
IT MEANS THE CITY CANNOT PRODUCE
ENOUGH WATER TO FIGHT FIRES, TO
RELIABLY FLUSH TOILETS AND TO
MEET OTHER CRITICAL NEEDS.
>> THE CITY OF JACKSON HAS
BATTLED WATER ISSUES FOR YEARS.
LET'S BEGIN WITH ISABEL GONZALES
WITH OUR TOP STORY.
GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU, ERICA.
THIS IS AN EMERGENCY.
THE GOVERNOR THERE TELLING THE
PEOPLE OF JACKSON NOT TO DRINK
THE WATER, SAYING THAT THE WATER
AND SEWER IS ON THE BRINK OF
COLLAPSE FOR 250,000 PEOPLE.
NOW, THE GOVERNOR WAS ALERTED
LAST WEEK THAT PUMPS AT ONE OF
THE CITY'S TWO WATER TREATMENT
PLANTS WAS DAMAGE.
THEN CAME ALL OF THE RAINFALL
AND THE FLOODING OF THE PEARL
RIVER.
THAT WAS THE STRAW THAT BROKE
THE CAMEL'S BACK.
THE WATER IS NOT SAFE TO DRINK
AND LITTLE TO NO WATER PRESSURE
FOR PEOPLE IN JACKSON.
THEY CAN'T FLUSH THE TOILETS OR
TAKE SHOWERS.
THE IMPACTS ARE ON AND ON.
BUSINESSES CANNOT CONTINUE ON
LIKE THIS.
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT HAS FOUND
HYDRANTS THAT HAVE RYEDRIED UP.
THIS IS SO INCREDIBLY
FRUSTRATING FOR PEOPLE OF
JACKSON THAT FACED WATER ISSUES.
LATELY, THEY FACE A BOIL WATER
NOTICE THAT'S BEEN IN EFFECT FOR
ABOUT A MONTH NOW.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, SHOPPERS ARE
RUNNING TO GROCERY STORES, TO
GAS STATIONS, TO PLACES LIKE
THIS KROGER, TRYING TO GET THEIR
HANDS ON BOTTLED WATER.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW LONG THE
SITUATION WILL LAST.
THE MANAGER HERE IS LIMITING THE
CASES TO FIVE PER PEOPLE,
ENSURING THAT PEOPLE GET ENOUGH
WATER.
LISTEN TO WHAT PEOPLE OF JACKSON
ARE FACING HERE.
>> AFTER WORK, I GET OFF LATE.
AND YOU COME IN THE STORE AND
IT'S EMPTY.
IT'S REALLY HARD.
ESPECIALLY WHEN I WORK AT A FOOD
RESTAURANT, AND WE'RE CLOSING
SOON.
>> Reporter: I WANT YOU TO LOOK
AT THE TIMELINE HERE.
THE MAYOR IS BLAMING STAFFING
SHORTAGES AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ON THE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THERE IS NO TIMELINE FOR WHEN
THE PLANT WILL BE BACK AT 100%.
THE MAYOR AND THE GOVERNOR
DECLARING STATE OF EMERGENCIES
OVER THIS WATER ISSUE.
4,500 NATIONAL GUARD MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN ACTIVATED TO HELP
DISTRIBUTE WATER.
ERICA?
>> ISABEL ROSALES LIVE IN
JACKSON FOR US THIS MORNING.
>>> ALSO WITH US, THE MAYOR OF
JACKSON.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US
THIS MORNING.
AS ISABEL JUST LAID OUT FOR US
THERE, IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW LONG
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY IS GOING
TO LAST.
THERE IS NO TIMELINE.
IS THERE A CONCERN BASED ON WHAT
WE'RE HEARING THAT THE CITY
COULD RUN OUT OF WATER?
EVEN WATER AVAILABLE FOR
FLUSHING TOILETS AND FIGHTING
FIRES AS WE HEARD?
>> LET ME THANK YOU FIRST AND
FOREMOST FOR HAVING ME, AS WE
LIFT UP THIS CHALLENGE, THAT WE
HAVE BEEN SUSTAINING FOR SOME
TIME NOW.
WE'VE BEEN LIFTING UP OUR WATER
CHALLENGES FOR THE BETTER PART
OF TWO YEARS, CRYING OUT FOR
ASSISTANCE THAT WE CAN GET.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT WE'VE SEEN
PERSISTENT GAINS IN OUR SYSTEM
OVERNIGHT.
THERE'S RESIDENTS THAT DID NOT
HAVE WATER YESTERDAY.
THEIR PRESSURE IS BEING
RESTORED.
WE WON'T BE HAPPY UNTIL EVERY
RESIDENT HAS WATER RESTORED TO
THEM.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES.
WHAT I HAVE BEEN LIFTING UP FOR
THE BETTER PART OF TWO YEARS.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF IF THE
SYSTEMS WILL FAIL, BUT WHEN THE
SYSTEMS WILL FAIL.
TO HAVE THE DECLARATION OF
EMERGENCY BY THE STATE AND TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ON THE
GROUND, IS WELCOME NEWS FOR US.
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED.
THIS IS HOW GOVERNMENT SHOULD
WORK.
WE SHOULD JOIN TOGETHER IN
SUPPORT OF OUR RESIDENTS.
I BELIEVE MY RESIDENTS IN
JACKSON ARE WORTHY OF SUPPORT.
>> WE NOTED, DECLARATIONS WILL
DO, SOMETHING THAT SOUNDS SIMPLE
BUT IT'S NOT.
YOU WERE NOT AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE WHEN THE GOVERNOR WAS
ANNOUNCING IT WAS A STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
HE WAS ASKED BY A REPORTER AND
TOLD THAT YOU WERE NOT INVITED.
>> I WAS NOT AWARE OF THE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
I WAS PART OF THE BRIEFING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
MEMA.
WE WELCOMED THE NEWS OF THEIR
SUPPORT.
SO, THAT WAS A GOOD DISCUSSION,
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A UNIFIED
FRONT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON
RIGHT NOW.
>> I UNDERSTAND A UNIFIED FRONT
IS KEY.
BUT IT SEEMS STAGGERING THAT THE
GOVERNOR WOULD TALK ABOUT THE
ISSUES OF JACKSON, A STATE OF
EMERGENCY, AND THE FACT THAT YOU
WEREN'T AWARE.
IS THAT FRUSTRATING TO YOU?
ARE YOU TWO TALKING?
ARE THE STATE AND THE CITY
TALKING IN ORDER TO GET THINGS
DONE?
>> IT'S WELL-DOCUMENTED THAT I
HAVE ATTEMPTED TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THE GOVERNOR.
FOR ME, THE PRIMARY FOCUS IS
SOLUTIONS.
THERE'S A TIME TO TALK ABOUT
THAT AND TO IMPROVE
COMMUNICATIONS AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO REACH OUT.
TODAY, I AM GLAD I HAVE THE
ASSISTANCE OF MEMA AND THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH, WORKING ON THE GROUND,
IN ORDER TO ENSURE RELIABILITY
IN OUR SYSTEM.
THAT'S WHERE MY FOCUS IS RIGHT
NOW AND WHERE THE PRIORITIZATION
HAS TO BE.
>> YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
FOR SOME TIME.
YOU HAVE BEEN WORKING TO BRING
IT TO THE FOREFRONT.
THE CITY'S CHIEF ENGINEER TOLD
"THE WASHINGTON POST" BACK IN
NOVEMBER, IT WOULD BE A BILLION
DOLLAR PRODUCT TO FIX THE WATER
SYSTEM.
FIXING THE SEWER SYSTEM WOULD BE
AN ADDITIONAL BILLION DOLLARS.
IS ANY OF THAT MONEY AVAILABLE?
>> WE CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE IT IN
OUR COFFERS.
WE HAVE BEEN USING EVERY
AVAILABLE DOLLAR WE HAVE TO
IMPROVE OUR SYSTEM.
WE HAVE, YOU KNOW, CREATED
ADDITIONAL -- A LARGER
DESCRIPTION LINE TO SOUTH
JACKSON, WHICH HAS INEQUITABLY
BEEN EFFECTED.
WE HAVE WEATHERIZED OUR PLANT.
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE AN AGED
SYSTEM OVER THREE DECADES OR
MORE, WE'RE FACING HOTTER
SUMMERS AND COLDER WINTERS AND
MORE PRECIPITATION ANNUALLY.
AND ALL OF THAT IS TAKING A TOLL
ON THE WATER DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE TO TAKE THE MEASURES TO
IMPROVE AND CREATE
SUSTAINABILITY IN OUR SYSTEM.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE MANY OF THESE,
IN MANY WAYS, ARE STOPGAP
MEASURES TO AVOID CRISES IN THE
MOMENT.
WHAT IS YOUR BIGGEST CONCERN IN
THE MOMENT?
>> MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS
UNDERSTANDING AND HAVING
PARTNERSHIP AT THIS BETTER LEVEL
SO WE CAN ALL PITCH IN AN EFFORT
TO MAKE IT MORE SUSTAINABLE.
IT WILL BE THE ABILITY TO TAKE
THE SYSTEM.
WE DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS TO DEAL
WITH 30 YEARS OF NEGLECT.
>> 30 YEARS OF NEGLECT.
AND YOU LOOK AT THIS, CLEAN
WATER, ONE OF THE BASIC SERVICES
THAT A GOVERNMENT PROVIDES.
30 YEARS IN.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN FIRST?
YOU TALK ABOUT NEGLECT IN
CERTAIN AREAS OF THE CITY.
WHY DID IT TAKE THIS, DO YOU
THINK?
TO PERHAPS START THAT
COMMUNICATION?
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU THINK YOU'RE
GETTING CLOSE TO A PLACE WHERE
YOU AND THE STATE WILL BE ON THE
SAME PAGE.
BUT YOU'RE NOT THERE YET.
>> I DON'T WANT TO HYPOTHESIZE
WHY IT'S TAKEN THIS LONG.
I AM GRATEFUL THAT THE RELIEF
HAS ARRIVED.
THAT'S WHERE MY FOCUS HAS TO BE
AT THIS MOMENT.
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS CHALLENGE.
WE'RE WORKING WITH A NUMBER OF
PARTNERS.
PARTNERS THAT ARE AIDING US TO
SUPPORT THIS SYSTEM.
BEYOND THE STATE AND BEYOND THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT WE'RE
RECEIVING.
I THANK THE KELLOGG FOUNDATION
AND THE WATER ALLIANCE FOR
TEAMING UP WITH US IN AN EFFORT
TO CORRECT THIS SYSTEM.
THAT'S WHAT OUR PRIMARY FOCUS
IS.
GOING AFTER EVERY STATE DOLLAR,
EVERY FEDERAL DOLLAR, IN ORDER
TO MAKE THE LONG OVERDUE
IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR SYSTEM.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
EPA THAT HAS MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON OUR STAFFING
CHALLENGES, WHICH, YOU KNOW, TO
THE LAYPERSON, SEEMS LIKE AN
EASY THING TO DO.
WHEN WE NEED CLASS-A OPERATORS
AND IT TAKES TWO YEARS FOR A
PERSON WITH A COLLEGE DEGREE TO
BECOME A CLASS-A OPERATOR, AND
SIX YEARS FOR A PERSON NOT WITH
A DEGREE TO BECOME A
CLASS-AOPERATCLASS-A
OPERATOR, IT TAKES A SIGNIFICA